reconstruire le centre aqualudique et la
halle du marché rénové l'école de la
malle me donne ou encore la protection
de l'environnement
pour sa nouvelle candidature grégory
gare et y impose une feuille de route
n'ont pas 2030 faire davantage d'actions
en faveur la transition écologique
notamment avec le renouvellement de
paris ouest qui va être un des grands
enjeux d'avenir du territoire avec la
ville de coignières décaissement se
taira nationaliste avec le carrefour
dame elle me donne la volonté de
transformer paris ouest vers des
aménagements beaucoup plus durable
grégory gars restiez repart avec les
mêmes ou presque sa liste sera
renouvelée de moitié
un moyen pour le maire sortant de
continuer ses projets initiés en 2014 un
mandat c'est court et je le vois tout ce
que j'ai mis en place avec mon équipe
commence à peine à sortir de terre
donc voilà il faut de nouveaux impulser
une nouvelle dynamique avec une équipe
renouvelée cette valeur de travail pour
la ville avant de la travaille pour soi
qui me moi qui me qui me plaisent
beaucoup
et après on a des valeurs pour les
générations il y en a beaucoup parlé ce
soir également vraiment de d'avoir une
ville pour toutes les générations que du
tout petits jusqu'aux seniors je suis
maman de deux enfants qui sont
maintenant scolarisés en primaire mais
qu'ils ont été
en crèche par la municipalité et tout ce
qui a été mis en oeuvre au niveau de la
petite enfance m'a beaucoup touché et je
trouve que c'est vrai qu'on a beaucoup
de chance en tant que maman d'avoir
toutes ces structures de crèches dans
ses autres projets grégory gars restiez
souhaite notamment lancé une mutuelle
communal le conseil des aînés sera en
charge du projet à maurepas le scrutin
municipal devrait voir s'affronter le
maire sortant à ismail havane et michel
chat pas tous deux élus aujourd'hui de
l'opposition